do you think that we need clearly to
find gender roles I think that men and
women have biological predispositions
that cause them to be better suited
toward different sorts of tasks at the
age of three boys show around about 50
to 70 better throwing accuracy compared
with girls women on the other hand have
better local recall and this is why men
always lose their keys but women can
tell where it is let's think about why
this might be the case men ancestrally
would have been looking at things that
were running perhaps sideways along to
them with a spear in the hand that means
that spatial rotation being able to
manipulate 3D objects in space in their
mind and then cause that to happen in
the real world would have been really
really adaptive also if women are
staying at home and they are moving
around the local area perhaps picking
berries perhaps making sure that all of
the children are being looked after
they're supposed to be good at that as
well it means that there are capacities
that each different has that dispose
them to doing different things